what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the eternals and
technically this is part of the judgment
day storyline so for those of you guys
who don't know about judgement day this
is the new event that marvel comics is
launching it's basically the avengers
versus the x-men versus the eternals
it's really really cool there are some
stories that are part of the lead up so
for example like benjamin percy's uh
x-force which we didn't actually finish
um a lot of you guys didn't really seem
to be didn't really seem to be feeling
it i wasn't really feeling it per se um
but we can kind of pick it back up and
for no other reason to kind of segue
into what's going on with x-force right
now i'm sure people in the comments will
say yes but i'm kind of looking more to
the the silent majority here to let me
know if you guys are interested in that
or not but what this does this this
second part second volume of the
eternals basically deals with thanos
rise to power now one of the things to
remember about the first arc that we did
because it's been a while right these
comics come out once a month so it's
been a little over six months since the
last time that we covered the eternals
that with with thanos rise he was
basically brought back by fostos and the
reason why is because the eternals had
realized that while they are technically
immortal in the sense that they can die
but they're brought back by the great
machine which is still kind of an
ambiguous concept in marvel comics
despite all the years that it's been in
existence that the caveat to this is
that when an eternal dies and they're
resurrected by the machine a human dies
in order for the eternal to be
resurrected and that was kind of the
story with icarus that there was a young
kid that he was charged with basically
protecting due to a kind of prophecy or
a vision that he'd had of the death of
this kid but ultimately that kid ended
up dying when icarus died and was
brought back so that's kind of the
struggle that icarus endures but the
eternals had realized this reality and
what this has done is it's created a
kind of rift among the eternals
themselves those who are perfectly okay
with it and those who don't like it
those who are avidly against it and so
what you have here there's a few things
that sort of go on one is something
called excess deviation now this is a
new concept introduced by kieran gillen
this doesn't really exist or hasn't
really existed in the history of marvel
comics when it came to the to the
deviants instead the way the deviants
worked is they were always just kind of
like a half-life right that deviants had
shorter life spans than eternals did
they were constantly engaged in struggle
and so on and so forth what kieran
gillen introduces here is that among the
deviant population there are basically
deviants that mutate and that in
mutating they usually become some kind
of a mindless more violent version of
themselves and they attack and kill and
even consume other deviants and so the
goal here is in what's really
interesting is you actually end up
having cersei who approaches crow of the
deviants and the reason why is because
with him being the leader some of the
eternals are actually considering
joining the deviants and actually
becoming a part of the deviant cause i.e
having their genes modified to where
they stop being eternals and they start
being deviant so this is really designed
to illustrate how far you know how far
in disagreement they are with like the
role the eternals play as it was
prescribed by the celestials now that's
one of the things that i do want to
specify here a lot of what kieran gillan
is doing here is totally reworking the
eternals mythos in marvel comics which
thank god because they haven't been
relevant in like 40 years
literally getting anybody to care about
the eternals is like pulling teeth now
the thing about this is that we end up
switching over to thanos now one of the
things to remember is that thanos had
died during the events of infinity wars
right that terrible ass story that
marvel did to try to tie into and try to
capitalize on the infinity war comic
everybody knew it was garbage everybody
was said was garbage and so people read
the first issue then never read it again
so the thing about this is that thanos
was basically restored by fostos now
remember fosus was one of the first
eternals uh that was resurrected
following the mass suicide of the
eternals previously and he was also one
of the first ones to realize that a
human has to die in order for eternal to
be resurrected and so him essentially
grabbing thanos who had previously been
dropped into a black hole essentially
following the events of a guardians of
the galaxy vol 5. he of course snatched
thanos from that black hole but thanos
is incomplete right he's basically a guy
who's there but he's not necessarily as
powerful as he used to be the promise
that was made between fostos and thanos
is that fostos would basically ensure
that thanos could be resurrected by the
great machine if he followed through
with the campaign in order to ensure
that fostos's plan of destroying the
great machine could basically come to
fruition and that anybody that could
stop them could basically be killed of
course the safeguard here is that if
thanos were to turn against fostos then
it would lead to a kind of destruction
of thanos himself now of course with
fostos being the only one to have that
information once fostos was killed and
then resurrected that information was
removed from him so for the moment
there's no one out there that knows the
failsafe on how to kill thanos at all
like no one has that information
save for druid but we'll actually talk
about that here in a second instead what
happens is that with this idea of thanos
basically you know at least thanos and
drew are kind of launching a campaign
with the unimod which is to say the idea
of xeros who is the prime eternal trying
to maintain his role and in turn
basically eliminating any and everybody
who either stands against the eternals
by trying to join the deviants due to
learning the truth of the eternals or
does not want to have their mind wiped
about the truth of the eternals that
what this does is with this civil war
taking place this kind of rift it
actually leads to eternals siding with
thanos and the big thing behind that is
it ultimately leads to thanos being
elected as prime eternal now there's
also a couple reasons for why this is
done the first is that unlike years past
when we had been taught by marvel comics
that thanos was an eternal with a
deviant gene instead what we're told by
kieran gillan here is that thanos was
actually a pure eternal right he was a
true earthly eternal not an eternal from
from uh from titan right not a titanian
eternal now how far reaching that goes
only time will tell because other
writers may ignore that some may choose
to lean into it but the thing about it
is that thanos has a rightful
opportunity to become the prime eternal
because he is a true eternal so it's
kind of like somebody who's never been a
citizen of the united states trying to
run for president you just can't do it
but then if he found out they actually
were a citizen of the united states then
they would have free reign to give it a
shot so long as they meet all the other
criteria that's basically what's going
on here and so with thanos actually
being elected the prime eternal which is
kind of nuts zoros turns on him tries to
attack him and thanos in turn kills
zoros for what's effectively heresy
trying to kill or trying to assassinate
the leader of the leader of the eternals
the prime eternal himself and so that's
when the question's asked by druid okay
now that you're prime eternal we can
access the great machine what else do we
do and the first thing thanos does is he
kills druid and the reason why is
because thanos knows that what druid
likely did is he backed up the
information fostos had on this the the
fail-safe for how to kill thanos so
druid's aware of it he knows how to do
that what thanos does by killing druid
is he basically ensures that druid will
be resurrected but by manipulating the
exclusion and the resurrection protocols
he removes that information from drugs
so druid now has no idea that thanos has
a fail safe and that if it's activated
thanos can successfully be killed and
even drug himself comes to that
realization when thanos resurrects him
but again you do get a bit more
discussion about excess deviation in all
honesty that's not going to be an
important theme until we get to the very
very end of this story that's where
excess deviation becomes important it is
a concept i want you to keep in the back
of your mind in terms of deviance
basically mutating and so on and so
forth but the big takeaway from this or
one of the big things here is back on
olympia where thanos tries to enter into
the great machine instead he can't
really bond with it and he doesn't
really know why there's simply there's
seemingly no information as to why it is
thanos cannot bond with the great
machine directly he's a true eternal he
should be able to bond with the machine
and he should be able to basically die
and then be reborn in a more pure form
so the question is why isn't that the
case why can't that be done and so as a
result of this what you end up having is
thanos kind of going on this quest to
understand why he can't bond with that
machine and even basically going and
trying to find faustos himself because
the idea is that with fostos with the
deviants fostos can be taken phosphos
can be tortured and then in turn fostos
can give the information to thanos and
so that's why you have these these
eternals that are residing within
lumeria the capital city of the deviants
having these kind of general discussions
about joining the deviant race and so on
and so forth and then thanos arrives and
then basically goes after fostos now
what's really cool here is that thanos
basically initiates a wholesale
slaughtering of the deviants he doesn't
really wipe them all out but it is an
absolute massacre and it's actually done
by way of something called the oceanic
watch right so what this what this
requires what we need to do here kind of
explain the oceanic watch is we kind of
have to dive back into a little bit of
eternal history this is something we
talked about before in the previous
videos or at least in the previous video
that we did but i do want to touch on it
again here so what you had in the early
days of the eternal empire the eternal
race is you had kronos and uranus now
uranus was an eternal who believed in
actually just conquering the earth and
killing everybody there so that the
eternals would be the only inhabitants
kronos did not believe that right kronos
did not necessarily follow in that
philosophy and a kind of war broke out
between the two this ultimately led to
uranus basically being forced to leave
earth and that when that happened of
course his people basically ended up
being killed and at least they they kind
of found themselves involved in their
own civil war then they all basically
died what we didn't know and what's
actually being explained here by kieran
gillen is that uranus and his forces
were resurrected by the great machine by
the exclusions of and so they've really
just kind of existed ever since the
important thing is that what you had was
a third brother named oceanus and the
way this played out is that looking at
his two brothers cronos and uranus
falling into a conflict like that the
fear of oceanus is that he could very
much fall down the same path in order to
ensure that didn't happen and what we
didn't know is that the forces of uranus
were actually resurrected by the great
machine and when that resurrection
happened no one knew what to do with
them they didn't know if they should
like keep them just in prison or what
the case may be because the fear was
they could fall back down the path of
instigating a civil war among the
eternals so what oceanus did is he
actually brought them in as his own ilk
and then formed the oceanic watch and so
in effect the oceanic watch has just
always kind of existed out there and so
they're described as a sword and a
scabbard or sword in a in a case you
know when they pull out that's on their
waist which is just waiting to be drawn
so whenever some kind of a conflict
breaks out and it requires the
intervention of the oceanic watch who
are by all standards of measurement the
deadliest force among all the eternals
they could be utilized so i hope this is
one of the things that you're realizing
that kieran gillen is wildly expanding
on the eternal mythos that the group is
much much larger than we initially
thought they were marvel's just kind of
changing things which again kudos to him
right they need that kind of expansion
they need that kind of change because
the eternals have just been they've just
been boring for years and years and
years but thanos basically attacking all
these deviants right why are you wiping
out most all of these deviants one of
the things that happens is he tells the
oceanic watch do not be lenient any
eternal that dies here we can resurrect
death has no meaning for these guys
particularly for fostos himself we can
resurrect him that while fostos does not
retain the information on the thanos
failsafe he still has all the
information on how thanos can be hooked
up to the great machine and so once it's
all said and done and once this massive
conflict ends that what you have is two
things taking place at the same time the
first is that the eternals and even the
deviants themselves don't really
understand their purpose right the
deviants don't really understand why
they exist and even marvel comics never
really explained why the deviants exist
we never learn their purpose in other
worlds on other planets right in other
parts of the of the universe for example
the scrolls we know how things played
out there that scrolls as they exist now
in marvel comics are the deviant scrolls
that the the the demon scrolls
themselves won out in the civil war
against the eternals and the baseline
scrolls with a dire race kind of going
on to do their own thing uh but in terms
of deviance on earth they don't know
their purpose which is really kind of
the bigger question of what's going on
with excess deviation so the eternals
and the deviants kind of working
together and tend to find an answer to
that question the second thing that goes
on here is that in order to gain an
answer to that question they have to
meet with a celestial but the reality is
they can't readily find one to meet with
save one which is avengers mountain so
this requires the eternals to actually
sneak into avengers mountain without
being detected because trespassing is
not readily accepted and if the eternals
showed up on the doorstep of the
avengers and said hey i know you guys
are currently housed inside of a of a
giant celestial we need to wake it up so
that we can have a conversation with it
that's a horrifying concept now
technically the the you know avengers
mountain that's celestial's dead right
he's called the progenitor basically
responsible for seemingly all life on
earth that's kind of how marvel
explained it but it's basically dead but
its spirit does live on that wicking its
spirit up could potentially create all
kinds of problems and so that's kind of
the main focus here at this point you
have that circumstance going on and then
you have thanos campaign so what you end
up doing is switching over to the to the
avengers themselves where cersei calls a
meeting or kind of a dinner date with
neymar the submariner now a lot of this
is also cersei being cersei right i mean
when you've been around for a million
years which is actually another huge
change kieran gillan revealed that the
eternals have been around for a million
years instead of like the 30 000 or so
that we're used to him over comics but
when you've been around for a million
years right you know you find ways to
keep yourself entertained and that's
kind of what happens here right you know
she enjoys the company of namor the
submariner in a few ways if you're
picking up what i'm putting down but for
thanos himself again trying to
understand how it is that he gets into
this machine he ends up basically
torturing fostos and that's a cool
moment here because not it's not cool
that he tortures him but it's a cool
exchange here because what it shows is
that fostos is far more kind and
reasonable than he would initially let
himself on to belief that he puts on
this air that he's just like this real
hard ass he's this real tough guy and
that's not necessarily the case that
what thanos does where you initially
have fossos who just refuses to answer
any questions and and thanos asks druid
like how in the world do you think that
we can possibly pull this off and
druik's response is well i mean you know
it really kind of depends on how you
look at it right you're looking at
things in a very basic and mundane way a
lot of it's because your mind's been
screwed up ever since you were dropped
into that black hole but the other
reason behind this is because you have
to have kind of a larger mind here right
he's like take for example the hammer of
thor he was like thor's hammer is
supposedly unliftable and i doubt that i
could lift it so the only way to lift
the hammer of thor is to apply
sufficient emotional leverage to make
thor lift the hammer for me and to use
it the way that i want him to and so the
larger point that he's making here is to
say sure fostos is an eternal and sure
fosos has been around for a million
years but at the end of the day
what is fostos at his core and at his
core fossos is human which means he can
be manipulated just like a human can be
and so what thanos does is he says like
i'm the prime eternal i have control
over all systems of this machine across
the world and he says this is the town
of little hollow it's a peaceful it's a
safe town and this will make the machine
create a plasma event beneath it tell me
what i want to know or i will render 10
000 souls into charcoal and the reality
here is faustos knows that thanos will
do it and so he spills the beans and he
says i reanimated you and made you part
of the machine in the few ways that i
could see but full integration i never
had the time to discover how to do it so
the reality is like those details are
confined to your parents only only sweet
son and a lars know how to how to put
you into the great machine only they
know how it can be done and so the
reality here is that where thanos finds
himself so frustrated because his
parents are dead the response of druid
is i mean you could just ask them
they're three cells over and again this
is another modification by kieran gillen
that eternals never die that eternals
are just resurrected and that's exactly
what happened here that when thanos had
killed his mother when she was younger
when he had killed his father when he
invaded titan and wiped out everybody
there during uh the thanos rising story
arc they weren't parrot they weren't
dead forever they were resurrected by
the machine and they've been kept hidden
ever since right just kind of locked in
these cells ever since and so you kind
of do a little bit of a time skip where
you basically have thanos who's just
been killing his parents over and over
again in order to kind of soften them up
and then turn interrogate them hoping he
can find the information that he wants
now for the eternals that showed up at
avengers mountain it is pretty cool the
way this works right the eternals have
been around for a very long time which
means they're very capable in stealth
and guile and so they're able to
successfully start sneaking around
through the building itself but one
thing to know is that in the end what
ends up happening is this actually star
brand that picks up on their presence
now kieran gillen kind of plays it fast
and loose here but one of the things he
says this right this this entire area
where they are is sufficient darkness if
you know how to hide this mission could
be easier than they feared however the
star brand is a planetary defense system
the eternals of the machine are a
planetary defense system you'd think
that this would put them all on the same
side you would be naive there is a
certain professional jealousy so in
effect what karen gillan is saying is
that while the machine as it was
seemingly created by the celestials to
kind of resurrect the eternals should
they ever die while that is a planetary
defense system as is the nature of the
star brand from the last white event the
truth about it kind of again playing a
little fast and loose here is that star
brand immediately becomes aware of the
fact that the eternals are here it's
really kind of curing gill and just
saying like this is how somebody found
out right i mean it's not like they they
stumbled across a laser beam right when
they broke the laser it set off all the
alarms right it wasn't really it's not
anything like that it's actually a
pretty elegant system to use right they
did set off a an alarm system it's just
the alarm system of starbrand now the
cool thing about this is remember star
brand is still a very young girl she's
not nearly as capable as she's going to
be later on down the line as her powers
begin to expand and so what happens is
that where star brand is like i see your
shadows over there that what is up what
is up taking place is sprite actually
uses his shape-shifting abilities
because in the in the eternals comics
sprite is a guy or at least he is now as
opposed to being a chick you know in the
the previous comics but says you know
sprite literally says like i'm your
magical sleep friend poople peeps
[Music]
and so literally just tricks a star
brand into thinking like i'm your i'm
your sleep friend and so let's go hang
out let's spend time together and
starbrand being a little girl and being
very naive just buys into it and then
runs off with sprite and so that leaves
the rest of the eternals there to end to
initiate their campaign and it's a cool
thing right i think it's a cool little
moment right it's one of those things
that shows that sprite is in a lot of
ways one of the more under appreciated
members of the eternals and that sprite
actually does have some pretty cool
moments in the comics but the other
thing about this kind of jumping back to
thanos and basically torturing his
parents for information the reality here
is they won't give him any information
and in fact he does the same thing with
them that he did with fossos where he's
like this is the town of little hollow
tell me what i want to know or i'm going
to kill everybody there the response of
thanos dad is like better that they burn
then we help you destroy more worlds
we're not giving you anything right
we're not giving you one bit of
information and that's what's so nuts
here is because all these stories are
starting to come to a head where thanos
is told by his parents we're not giving
you any information that town can burn
for all we care thanos hits the button
and opens up a plasma event beneath the
town so now it's just a countdown to
when this entire town gets destroyed now
following that you pick up with ajax
who's basically communicating with the
uh with the celeste or at least trying
to talk to it and one of the things to
remember is that while she is
communicating with its ghosts
essentially that celestials are very
very particular right for celestial
they've been around for billions and
billions of years right so what is five
minutes to us is an instant to them
right to have a kind of ceremony where
you communicate and you talk to a
celestial it takes a while just to get
through the opening conversation right
to present yourself and to show that
you're a person is even worth their
attention in the first place and that's
what goes on with ajax where she's
communicating with the celestial here
and talking to it it's gonna take some
time which means some time has to be
bought here now in order to ensure that
this time is given to the avengers kingo
comes up with this genius idea where
he's like i'm scolothar the
destructorite right just like this kind
of crazy thing just basically concocting
some villain out of nowhere that doesn't
exist and saying like you know my my
swords will destroy you and you know
i've traveled across you know a trillion
dimensions to face the avengers of earth
you know i'm going to kill you guys and
the avengers are initially kind of like
what like this is kind of stupid but
like once they start fighting this guy
they start realizing okay this guy is
really capable of course it isn't
eternal but one of the things to know
about kingo is he's wildly capable as a
fighter right kygo as some people also
call him but he's wildly capable as a
fighter right i mean just it's like the
fighter of the bunch besides then athena
i think is the more capable fighter of
the two but kiko's pretty solid in his
own right he's simply just there kind of
buying time for uh for at least ajax to
communicate with uh with the celestial
the reality here is it also draws the
attention of the each the other eternals
themselves icarus and athena and so on
and so forth because what they realize
is that thanos having activated that
aspect of the machine and getting ready
to wipe out that little town requires
them to intervene in order to save it
and so while that's going on of course
you have kingo facing off against the
avengers and saying like oh no you know
my earthly death warning sensors have a
message the town of little hollow is
about to be consumed by fire you should
go you know and so like the avengers
initially think like he's full of crap
but the reality is like they start to
realize he's actually telling the truth
what iron man chimes in and he's like no
he uses his satellites and realizes
there's plasma venting under that town
we need to go in response they basically
ended up you know end up taking off and
this allows kingo to kind of be
quote-unquote defeated by the avengers
in a last-ditch move which black panther
realizes okay this guy's an eternal
something bigger is going on here right
like they end up responding as well and
so what it does is it leads to a kind of
fight between the eternals and the
avengers when they arrive on the scene
right the eternals literally tell the
avengers like we've got it sorted you
guys need to leave and the response of
the avengers is no you need to tell us
what's going on this leads to both
groups coming to blows with each other
now the cool thing about this and one of
the things that's interesting is that
athena basically creates a kind of
portal that whisks echo away because
echo is in possession of the phoenix
force and the the eternals know how
powerful the phoenix is right they know
that it's not going to hold her forever
but they do know she's powerful and so
one of the things to realize here is
that the fight between these two is
pretty interesting you don't normally
see the avengers fighting the eternals
very often so you have thor fighting
athena you've basically got carol
danvers and you've got iron man fighting
their guys right i mean fighting icarus
which is really cool to be honest with
you like i'm really excited about that
but then you finally have ajax who
breaks through to the celestial ghost
starts communicating with it and it
starts spilling its guts and when that
happens she ultimately keeps attacking
it now we're not told explicitly what
ajax was told by the celestial we're
simply just told or at least kind of uh
kind of given here that whatever it was
she was told was pretty significant so
much so that it reduces her to tears and
is like why did the gods make us this
way right so whatever information she
was given was pretty significant again
that information kind of feeds into the
larger story arc of avengers x-men
eternals axe and that whole event
unfolding itself as for the eternals
facing off against the avengers you know
one of the funny things here is that
once everything's all said and done and
ajak reveals that she gets her
information the eternals are kind of
like oh no you defeated us and then you
know they basically end up leaving of
course the arrival of echo kind of helps
a little bit but the bigger theme that's
hit on here by kieran gillan kind of
seems to be if the the avengers are able
to overcome the eternals it's because
the eternals allowed them to now there
is a little bit of caveat that goes on
with both of these guys for example um
what the eternals lack in comparison to
the strength of thor they make up for in
terms of their experience in battling
just things along those lines right so
it's not not as though they don't really
possess the same kind of power or
strength it's simply just that we're
talking about a situation where one
group isn't so much weaker than the
other as they're more experienced than
the other there's no discernible reason
why they wouldn't be able to come out on
top here now do i think that's accurate
not entirely sure right i'm not 100 sure
that i agree with that but the truth
about this is that switching back to
thanos because the information wasn't
readily available or given to him what
he ends up doing is tracking down the
way in which he was created by swisson
and lars because that's one of the
things to keep in mind swiss on and lars
and even the eternals themselves that's
one of the things that kieran gillen is
kind of building up here they don't
procreate in the traditional way which
is to say suisan and lars did not
procreate right they didn't touch
naughty bits and then like thanos and
eros popped out some time later that
they effectively created them right just
because of the fact that eternals are
not really capable of procreation and
that's one of the things to keep in mind
that the eternals were referred to each
other as like uncle or father or son or
mother it doesn't really work that way
instead the way this works is you kind
of have more like roles right so the the
phrase father is more akin to like
president or governor or like captain or
something like that it's a it's a kind
of hierarchical rank as opposed to like
you are my biological father something
along those lines if you guys understand
what i'm saying but ultimately even
after gaining that information thanos
tries to bond himself through the
machine but he can't right he can't
resurrect himself through the machine
and the reason why when the question's
asked thanos basically just kind of has
is is sort of sick of it the reason why
as this explained to him is because he
simply just mutated far too much he's
not what his parents made him when he
was originally created when he was
originally made he was a pure eternal
albeit with a bit of the deviant gene
hence the reason he looks the way he
looks or at least that seems to be the
case but the truth is that over the
course of his life but you know for one
reason or another whether it's his own
modifications the modifications death
made to him whatever the case is he's
not physically and even on a biological
level the same being he was so thanos
trying to enter the machine and be
resurrected is like trying to fit a
square peg into a round hole it just
doesn't work and so ultimately thanos as
he exists now will simply just stay that
way right he's just kind of a thanos the
way he is here at the moment and so what
he ends up doing is in true thanos
fashion basically activates a kind of
self-destruction device or a destructive
device that will ultimately annihilate
the entirety of the world right it'll
destroy the entire earth itself and so
what goes on is the eternals arrive on
the scene in the realm of titanos which
of course the avengers cannot access and
the eternals even say that themselves
right like a world ending events being
initiated here guys you have to let us
go we have to go deal with this right as
much as we would love to stay and fight
you here avengers we have much bigger
fish to fry and what's going on here is
a place that you simply just can't
access right you just cannot get to this
location so uh a few things you got
gotta know thanos is back he's here on
earth we kind of brought him back at
least fostos did what the eternals did
is how you're gonna look at it he's a
prime eternal now and uh he wants to
destroy the world so we gotta go deal
with him we know you didn't know uh we
probably should have told you but hey
you know
you live and learn right so it's like we
got to go deal with this
so we'll see what we see and they
basically end up racing off to titanos
to deal with thanos so it's basically
the the eternals themselves that have to
face off with thanos directly now the
funny thing about this is remember even
though thanos is not necessarily as
powerful as he traditionally is he's
still way beyond any of the eternals
here he's more than enough for any of
the eternals and he demonstrates that
icarus is really the more capable at
least the most capable of all the
eternals think of him as kind of like
the thor or the incredible hulk of the
avengers right the real heavy hitter and
the guy that can hold his own but even
he doesn't stand much of a chance
against thanos none of them do and it's
only a matter of time before thanos
kills them all but then suddenly stano
starts mutating and literally starts
dying his body starts breaking down and
the reason why and what he's told
literally is kind of this voice that
comes out of nowhere and it says i have
been programmed so that if anything
classified as the hidden armory of
uranus was ever accessed which is what
thanos did to initiate this kind of
world ending event it says i would
activate fastest's fail safe codes when
the countdown reached a certain dramatic
point the order has a note attached to
it if you are hearing this it is because
you wiped my mind presumably to make me
forget to use the failsafe so i left
this little surprise to activate in case
you triggered a world ending event that
druid knowing it was only a matter of
time before thanos killed him and
resurrected him to prevent him from
knowing how to activate the fail-safe
device had created a plan c to his plan
b and his plan c was this that if thanos
triggered a world world-ending event
which is exactly what he did that it
would initiate the fail-safe protocols
of fostos and it would kill thanos which
is exactly what's been done which is an
amazing moment
so thanos is dead again and in all
honesty
i'm kind of sad about that i missed the
days of like like you know jim starling
in the 1980s when thanos was just an
absolute monster but that's the comic
book hipster in me that doesn't want to
see things change i don't i mean i could
see why they did this but i'm kind of
tired of seeing thanos being a guy that
just sort of gets just gets his cheeks
clapped all the time by just any
swinging dick you know what i mean like
if thanos is gonna get killed let it be
by somebody who's just a hoss but with
that being said guys there is an
instance where the eternals kind of fill
in the gaps a little bit they sort of
present a few things to the avengers
kind of let them know know what's going
on they do stay hands off right at their
at least they feel the avengers on on
everything that had happened but they do
kind of stay away right the trust
between the avengers and the uh and the
eternals is a little bit questionable
and it kind of makes sense i mean one of
the universe's deadliest beings had just
been running around earth and the
eternals just never thought to tell the
avengers right so i mean that's going to
create some trust issues you know like
hey guys the mad titan demigod who once
blinked out half the life of the
universe he was right over there for
like the last six months my bad
right that's gonna create some issues
but the big takeaway from this and
what's kind of the big thing is that
following the death of thanos that druid
is elected the prime eternal and one of
the first things he does is he tells the
machine with the new deviant database
can you locate what beings the deviants
have catalyzed where can we find deviant
dna i.e anybody out there who was not
traditionally a deviant who's been
corrupted by deviant dna and the
response to the machine is yes earlier
areas with deviant-derived dna have been
highlighted and what it shows is just
kind of everybody right in some capacity
right because deviants exist all over
the world so the response of druid is
okay narrow down the search run these
filters right and give me give me like a
new list right i don't want to know the
deviants that exist in the the core of
the world they're just kind of spread
all over the place i don't want to know
about some deviant that bang some random
chick or anything like that because i
don't know like she's into that kind of
stuff like i want to know deviants that
are not supposed to be there and what
ends up happening is it shows him two
locations the first one is the capital
city of lumeria which he's already aware
of the second one he says zoom in on
that island there are a ton of deviants
there and that's when the machine tells
him that's krakowa the capital of the
mutants they've recently expanded to
mars what kieran gillen and marvel
comics look like they're doing here is
they're changing the history of the
x-men and saying the x-men are not the
result of some x-gene that's activated
that the x-men that mutants as they
exist in marvel comics are actually just
deviants with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end i'm
sure it's gonna piss off a lot of people
thank you all for watching i will catch
you all later
peace